foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Hogwarts Headmaster Albus
Dumbledore and trying to unravel one of
his dirtiest darkest Secrets as early as
the Philosopher's Stone in the first
chapter no less we hear Dumbledore
mention a certain scar in the
conversation with McGonagall but it's
not the scarred you probably thought of
Harry scar of Legend it's actually one
of Dumbledore's own scars if the first
place your mind went to was emotional
scars then that would make perfect sense
as Dumbledore who lived quite the
tumultuous life would be riddled with
them but in this instance we're talking
about a real Bonafide Scar the following
is Dumbledore's response to mcgonagall's
query about whether or not he could
remove Harry's scar even if I could I
wouldn't scars can come in handy I have
on myself above my left knee that is a
perfect map of the London Underground
for those unaware the London Underground
is a public transport network of
underground Railways in London also
called the tube in this case Dumbledore
is referring to the tube map which is a
map used by Travelers on the Underground
however it's not simply an overlay of
the railway lines onto a map of London
it's a simplified version of lines to
make it easier to follow some may have
interpreted this little quip as some
sort of joke but as it happens JK
Rowling has since confirmed that this
scar on Dumbledore's left knee was very
much real the problem however is that
she never revealed how he got it even
avoiding the answer at a public q a
seven years after the first book's
release how did Dumbledore get his scar
of the London Underground you may find
out one day I'm very fond of that Scar
and now 25 years after the release of
the first book this question like so
many others remains unanswered today
we're going to be diving in and figure
out the cause of Dumbledore's famous
scar I've got two very different
theories my first theory is that
Dumbledore got the scar while trying to
protect his sister Ariana when Ariana
Dumbledore was just six years old she
was brutally attacked by three muggle
boys it was this incident that led to a
permanent inability to control her
magical abilities as well as the
imprisonment of the Dumbledore family's
patriarch Percival Dumbledore when
Percival first got the news about what
had happened to his daughter he went and
furiously attacked the three muggle boys
in a bout of range for his crimes he was
sentenced to Azkaban and after he got
locked up the family moved from mold in
the world to godrick's hollow proud and
haughty Kendra Dumbledore could not bear
to remain in mold on the walled after
her husband percival's well-publicized
arrest and imprisonment in Azkaban she
therefore decided to uproot the family
and relocate to godrick's hollow the
village that was later to gained
scene of Harry Potter's strange escape
from you know who with Dumbledore's
father out of the picture Albus knew
that he would have to step up and be
strong for his family with Percival
locked away who would protect Ariana my
theory is that after moving to godrick's
hollow bullying of Ariana persisted but
with no passive all-around to step in
Albus had to do it it was now his
responsibility and on one occasion while
protecting Ariana Alba sustained some
injuries specifically a scar that oddly
looked like a map of the London
Underground and even though Albus wanted
to defeat these bullies and to punish
them he couldn't because you see Albus
one of the most powerful wizards of his
time couldn't use his vast magical
Arsenal if he did he would have secured
the same fate as his father a sentence
to Azkaban instead Alba simply took the
beating and allowed his sister to escape
from that moment on became entirely
clear that Ariana was too vulnerable to
be out on her own and the family tried
their best to accommodate an interesting
but certainly more sheltered life for
her but now you may be asking yourself
wasn't Dumbledore supposed to be fond of
this scar why would he be fond of a
memory that involved him getting beaten
up the truth is Albus did very little
for his sister in his early years and
her death which came almost as a direct
result of him putting her In Harm's Way
was one of his greatest regrets her
death was the reason Dumbledore put on
Marvel gaunt's ring it's the reason he
had no fear of death
dying just meant that he might be
presented with another opportunity to
see his sister and make amends
Dumbledore was fond of the scar on his
knee because it represented protecting
his little sister while not letting his
emotions get the better of him he was
fond of it because it symbolized one
profoundly kind act towards the sister
that he otherwise let down again and
again it was the one time he truly
stepped up and allowed himself to be the
big brother that she needed in death we
can only hope that they were reunited my
second theory is that Dumbledore got the
scar during his Final Duel with
Grindelwald in 1945 a personal reminder
to Dumbledore of the famous Jewel that
many would describe as the most epic in
Wizarding history they say still that no
Wizarding Jewel ever matched that
between Dumbledore and Grindelwald in
1945. those who witnessed it have
written of the terror and the ore they
felt as they watched these two
extraordinary Wizards to battle
Dumbledore's trying time and its
consequences for The Wizarding World are
considered a turning point in magical
history to match the introduction of the
international statute of secrecy or the
downfall of he who must not be named
Alba Dumbledore was ever proud or vain
he could find something to value in
anyone however apparently insignificant
or wretched and I believe that his early
losses endowed him with great humanity
and sympathy what if Dumbledore got a
scarved London Underground because he
jeweled Grindelwald inside of the London
Underground with spells blasting all
over the place it doesn't sound entirely
outside the realm of possibility for a
spell to have bounced off of a wall map
becoming somewhat infused with the
pattern and subsequently permeating
itself into Dumbledore's skin spells in
Harry Potter have historically exhibited
all sorts of strange properties and this
seems like just the kind of strange but
oddly significant thing that could
happen to someone like Dumbledore
the only problem with this theory is
that the latest Fantastic Beasts films
seem to predominantly take place in
countries beside Britain and I've always
been of the impression that their final
Jewel took place on grindelwald's home
turf this is reinforced by the fact that
Grindelwald ended up being imprisoned in
nermanguard rather than Azkaban
furthermore if this was indeed how he
got the scar why would this scenario
cause Dumbledore to be fond of it given
how close Grindelwald and Dumbledore
were you'd imagine that a scar reminding
him of their battle with illicit bad
memories but here's the thing defeating
Grindelwald wasn't all bad by defeating
Grindelwald Albus Dumbledore helped Save
The Wizarding World and many many lives
he put others first and himself second
yes he had to fight the man that he once
loved but in one Fell Swoop he was able
to both save the day and keep
Grindelwald alive grindelwald's defeat
also represented a shift in his
perspective after being finally defeated
by Dumbledore he inevitably came to the
realization that he had always been
wrong and this is reflected by the fact
that he never even tried to escape
nerman God he knew that he got what he
deserved and that he would need to pay
his Penance Zing Grindelwald like that
must have brought Dumbledore great joy
despite the length that he had to go to
prompt this realization and that's it
for this video if you enjoy the content
please be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
foreign